what's up everyone this is anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain simply the
best podcasting crypto let's kick this
thing off
connor brown is a Stanford law student
and frequent Bitcoin Twitter commentator
in this conversation we discuss smart
contracts common misunderstandings of
Bitcoin why every political candidate
should love Bitcoin and the relationship
between open source software power and
institutions in the modern day I really
enjoyed this conversation and I hope you
do as well skirt school want to know who
has the best URL crypto comm that's
right
crypto comm they're a crypto platform
with one goal mother and mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
comm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you'll plug it in
connect to your Wi-Fi five minutes or
less you're mining Bitcoin all you have
to do is control it from the mobile app
they provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mine
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com tell them Tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block by
and receive 6% annual interest paid
monthly and cryptocurrency 6% is an
absurdly high rate it's the best rate in
the industry I highly suggest you go
check out block Viacom / pop again
that's blocked by calm / pop to sign up
and start earning crypto today if you
follow Bitcoin and crypto you've
probably heard of eToro they're the
world's number one social trading
platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it - and guess what
they just launched the United States
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or Oh calm again that's eToro
comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony Pompano is
a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
pains expressed by pump or his guests on
this podcast are solely their opinions
and do not reflect the opinions of
Mourne Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang-bang sitting here with
Connor we were in San Francisco right
now thanks so much for for coming up to
City doing this yeah thank you so much
for having me here it's it's really an
honor to be on your podcast and be able
to talk all right so I think a lot of
people have they've seen your tweets
they know that you're quite bullish on
on Bitcoin and a lot of the things that
are going on in the ecosystem but they
don't know much about you to start so a
little bit about your background and
kind of how you got to Stanford and
ended
yeah so it's it's been a long journey so
I'm right now I'm on my last year of law
school at Stanford I'm originally I just
went straight through from from
undergrad I studied philosophy and
sociology and then I decided that you
know a lot of the things I was learning
about we're pretty pie in the sky and I
wanted to sort of make more of a
tangible change and to me that seemed
like going to law school and sort of
looking at you know where the actual you
know power structures are but you know
when I was in law school I wanted to
sort of look at the most innovative you
know new types of law and so when I
heard about this thing called smart
contracts then I was naturally sort of
drawn to that and I think over you know
the past you know year and a half now
I've been sort of digging through this
and trying to take a first principles
approach and just stack up the arguments
my background is in debate and figure
out where the arguments are for you know
what the strengths and weaknesses of
these systems are and where the value is
that was sort of what I really really
cared about and ultimately while I was
you know initially really excited about
smart contracts they seemed like a
really novel approach I became pretty
disillusioned with them but in the
meantime I found Bitcoin which was much
much more interesting actually so that's
kind of how I ended up here all right so
before we go into Bitcoin specifically
let's talk about the smart contracts
kind of what was the the dream if you
will and then kind of what took you off
that path or maybe got you to be a
little bit more bearish on it then you
initially thought you would be yes so
initially smart contracts seemed like
sort of the natural evolution of you
know we have all of these written paper
contracts or you know we have all these
lawyers who are working all these hours
on on drafting up these long contracts
and wouldn't it be great if we just
removed all that friction and if we
somehow you know just had it all
automated by a computer and computers
took care of it and I think that's a
pretty sexy idea because law is you know
pretty much universally hated seen as
greedy middlemen and you know a lot of
that is true in a lot of ways there are
a lot of inefficiencies in the law but I
think that
while a lot of legal structures are
inefficient there's a lot of very
important concepts that are sort of
overlooked and thrown you know you kind
of throw the baby out with the bathwater
with that sort of critique and so I
think initially I had that that hope of
sort of making things more efficient but
when I dug into it you know a smart
contract is really not anything more
than code and while code is extremely
powerful it really has only very
specific logical parameters that it can
encapsulate so it can you know perform
whether or not something is true or
false based on the parameters that are
fed to it but that doesn't mean that it
can handle the nuance of what a legal
contract really represents a legal
contract at its most basic basic level
is a meeting of the minds between two
people so if Connor and pom want to
enter into an agreement you know and we
want to you know let's let's say we have
like a we're I'm gonna be selling you
something and we're entering into a
contract and you're gonna be purchasing
these on a recurring basis you know
there's a lot of things that I might put
in that contract that could trigger
certain clauses or could trigger
different things and the smart contract
approach would say oh that's great
because we can just write a nice little
logical function that will trigger if
one of these clauses happens but the
real world is much much more sticky and
subjective and gray than black and white
yeah it's almost like the smart concert
is only as good as the input and the
structure of the contract itself right
so like if you create something that's
so binary or black and white one you're
counting on accurate information being
inputted into the contract and then two
you're counting on the fact that you at
some previous point in time understood
fully the entire situation so that smart
contract can encapsulate all of that
information to make a decision that ends
up being accurate or correct the problem
I think you're highlighting is one it's
almost impossible for you to understand
the full situation in advance and then
two is if you can only get contracts to
make binary yes/no decisions that leaves
a lot of edge cases etc that are either
unaddressed or - even worse
neglected and when they get neglected
that's usually where you see the issues
pop up there I think that's exactly
right because you know you have this
nuance a smart contract just can't
handle if I'm writing a contract if you
read a leave a contract all throughout
it you're gonna see the words material
you're gonna see the words reasonable
how does a logical true/false function
parse out reasonableness or are these
sorts of things but do you think that
the use of material reasonable etc
because those are human constructs and
left up to be very subjective kind of
determinations that's actually the wrong
way like it's almost like if you flip it
on tenth right so if we try to fit smart
contracts into the current legal
structure you get these challenges yeah
but if you flip it you say no actually
the fact that everything isn't black and
white in the legal language and we
should move towards black and white then
some our contracts are suppose a better
way to do law rather than the subjective
version we have today I think that's the
dream certainly and I think that's how
it's pitched the problem is that you and
I both know the world is very great and
and like I said contracts are meeting of
the minds and you and I can both think
that we agree on something
we can totally shake hands and think
like we're 100% in agreement and we will
have different subjective understandings
of the world and that's why you know
when there's a contract dispute you need
to have something like a judge because
you know a judge if it was really that
simple then we would have contracts that
are written in black and white language
and a judge would say okay this is how
this is resolved it's pretty simple but
you know it's it's much more difficult
than that you have litigation that goes
on for very long times for very very
high dollar deals because you know when
you're weighing these things you have to
think about justice and fairness and
reasonableness and all these sort of
higher level concepts that can't be
reduced to code and while you can
abstract some of that away certainly
you're not going to get much more
functionality than like a vending
machine yep and that's useful but is
that going to I think specifically the
promise of smart contracts is well we
can take the entire financial
infrastructure and put that into smart
contracts but this goes back to
financial contracts are contracts of
trust right if I'm entering into an
agreement
you let's say we're doing a credit
default swap right and I'm trying to
make sure that you're a trustworthy
counterparty there's a lot of things
that can go wrong in a credit default
swap we can have a lot of disagreements
on what does it mean to default what
does it mean to be late on a payment
what does it mean for all these
different triggering clauses of the
payout happening and how much of those
the nuances and challenges are
disagreeing between you and I like think
of it as the two parties in the
transaction versus there's external
forces that could be macro or micro but
those external forces can change in real
time what you and I agree on right it's
almost like you know if you look at a
contract a lot of times there's multiple
subjective if-then type scenarios right
so if you do this then you're allowed to
pay on this date but if you prepay then
you know you do something else or
whatever the scenario is to me it feels
like a lot of times those external
forces at play there's a lot of
renegotiating right there's a lot of
kind of rewriting contracts there's ways
that some of this stuff plays out again
you just can't pre predict and that's
part of the problem right there orally
just the chance I know is that necessary
promise is a challenge no I think that's
totally part of it you know you have
contingencies that just can't be
accounted for and black and white and
mutable software yeah like what sort of
hedge fund would ever enter into an
immutable contract when you know what
happens if their lead trader goes skiing
and you know has credible brain damage
and now they can't quite make the
decisions that were and they have to in
turn some contingency pram what my fair
to say that if you look at the body of
law today there are very distinct areas
where some more contracts will become
pervasive quickly in the sense of it's
very black-and-white it's very easy to
implement this and and there's very
little controversy in that
implementation versus other areas where
it's so subjective as smart contractor
going to really struggle to be
implemented so kind of the
implementation isn't even black and
white we get some areas that get
automated in law and some that don't or
do you feel like this is going to be
either the industry adopts smart
contracts where they completely denied
I mean I I think in a way smart
contracts are what we've been seeing
like software's eating the world and
smart contracts you know when when I go
and buy my airline tickets like it's
it's a smart contract in the sense that
it's just a one-time deal and like I
type in my my credit card info or
hopefully I pay with lightning and then
I just boom it spits out the ticket and
that and that's basically a smart
contract it's a little digital vending
machine why that needs to be on
blockchain a little bit unclear yep and
I think that will increasingly see that
and things will get more and more
efficient in that direction but a smart
contract for complex financial
agreements where I mean if I'm giving
you a loan I need to know who you are I
need to know yeah why I trust you
right and that's something that is
incredibly difficult on smart contracts
and you know I think a lot of the hype
is well we're eventually going to get to
identity
we'll eventually be able to sort this
out you know we haven't quite solved
identity yet yep and you know that is a
incredibly difficult problem because
identity isn't just knowing who you are
because all identity is relational right
you might be pumped to me on Twitter but
you might be someone else to your family
members or you might be someone else to
your government right and so who you are
your identity is relational yeah and
that's that's really important for a
contract because that is how you manage
enforcement yep how do I enforce a
contract against you I always think
about this as like almost pseudonyms
right of like you have you and like who
you actually are as a human but the way
that you interact with colleagues in a
corporate environment versus your
significant other versus like maybe you
play you know baseball on the weekends
with your friends or whatever you're
actually different people to all of
those different groups they see you as
the person you're acting at in that
scenario is who you are right so like
your significant other however they see
you acting in that situation that's who
they believe you to be right if they
then see you acting how you act in the
corporate environment with your
corporate colleagues they a lot of times
say is that what you do at work right
look at like it's almost like they've
seen like a different side of you
is very contrasting to your original
identity we see that in human
relationships
it becomes very weird when also now you
have software to address all of those
different identities in a way where was
tie it all back to one individual but we
have to account for these different
identities in contracts etc totally and
I think that goes to the idea of this
you know we're gonna have D 5 we're
gonna decentralize finance but you know
if I'm Morgan Stanley right and I'm
trying to determine if I want to lend
shares of a stock that you want to short
to your hedge fund then I need to know
who you are because I need to assess
your creditworthiness what are your
other contracts what are your what is
your trading history who are you as a
counterparty right and identity is very
having a stable not synonymous but the
true identity of who you are it's very
important for me assessing your
creditworthiness and actually making a
deal with you in the first place yeah if
I don't know you I'm not gonna trust you
and Trust is very important in making
these things more efficient and kind of
like being you know greasing the wheels
of commerce because you've done a lot of
these transactions and I know that if
things go south then I can enforce a
judgment against you in the United
States and so your identity is actually
very crucial yeah I'm having a Sudha
nonnamous identity doesn't give you
those same guarantees I can't know if
this is the you know the 20th time you
try borrowing with me and you screwed me
over 19 times and now I'm supposed to
trust you I can't know who you are where
you're domiciled so I can't know where
to get a judgment against you and so
because of that I have to fall back on
all right I'm gonna over Claddagh like
collateralize everything yeah I need to
lend you $100 I need 150 upfront yep
just to make sure you don't run away
with my money well it's just something
we asked what banks do today right who
did lend money to people who don't
actually need the money yeah totally
they if you need the money they don't
want to lend it to you because they're
scared you won't pay them back yeah and
even when you don't have sued anonymous
identities when you just have your
actual identity and real credit score
with like peer-to-peer lending like
Lending Tree Lending Club you know those
things went so far south because people
just run away with the money and it's
it's really really hard to have trust
and that requires rigorous identity and
I know that's not sexy to the
decentralised all the things you know so
apply the cyberpunk ideals to you know
modern finance but lending finance is a
trust based interaction yep and it is
you know money Bitcoin you can take
trust out of it and you actually have a
much much better product yep
you take trust out of lending so I don't
know who I'm giving my money to and
you're going to have a nightmare on your
hands yeah well it's only a nightmare if
you don't have the order of over
collateralization right like one of the
things that I'm really interested in the
spaces so if I put Bitcoin less I take
$100 with a Bitcoin and I put it into
block by or what these other platforms
and I received 30 or 50 dollar US dollar
loan right the trust is or the need for
trust is minimized because it is so over
collateralized they have control of my
asset or collateral and then I'm able to
take a loan but to your point there's
very few people in that situation who
you know it's a very nuanced use case
where if I have enough collateral to
posed in that scenario to then receive a
30 to 50 percent LTV loan normally it's
the exact opposite right it's hey I want
to buy a house I put down 10 20 %
somebody gives me 80% of the value of
the home and then I'll pay it off over
time there's no collateralization there
and that's where I get any becomes
important that's that's exactly right
and so the over collateralization like
it has some use cases for sure I'm not
saying it has zero but is it going to
replace the wheels of Finance not at all
because you're gonna see two options you
can either tell us who you are and you
know maybe you post 20 or 30% collateral
at a clearing house or you completely
over collateralize and it's almost
impossible for you to even make money
you have much less you know how do you
start a business where you need
financing to start a company but you
have to give me more money than you
already have
just to get the loan for the company I
mean that confidence I never work for
sure so I switch gears a little bit
you've done a bunch of writing and
tweeting recently about like the common
misconceptions of Bitcoin and we're
talking about trust earlier in and
frankly I I think they've about there's
this idea that even like the most
hardcore bitcoiners trust certain
narratives right and so that doesn't
mean that the narratives right or wrong
it's just that there is definitely
consensus thought around certain ideas I
want to start with one that you recently
wrote about bitcoin is not deflationary
right so what
did you kind of what was the point of
that kind of talk track for you and kind
of why you felt compelled of like hey
this narrative something that a lot of
people have consensus around but it
actually might not be true yeah so
there's a couple of these floating
around and I wrote that piece
specifically because you know you hear
this talked about a lot especially in
mainstream economic circles sort of this
specter of deflation that's haunting the
economy and central bankers are doing
everything they can to prevent deflation
and so deflation is seen as this this
pretty negative thing and so I wanted to
sort of write this article to say you
know it's easy to say bitcoin is
deflationary in terms of while prices
are going to go down but if you look at
the actual monetary supply the monetary
supply is not decreasing so in a very
strict sense of deflation being a
deflation and inflation being decrease
or increase in the basement money supply
bitcoin is not deflationary it's it's
actually constant because it levels off
to that 21 million hard cap okay so this
and this is a nuance piece of rates are
there a separation I think the first is
the the disinflationary monetary supply
schedule so this is the the amount of
Bitcoin that is getting injected into
the circulating supply right so there's
21 million we know as a hard cap of kind
of total supply right but today we just
crossed over 18 million that have now
been put into supply and and that will
continue to accelerate or increase over
time but actually it won't accelerate or
increase over time but the amount every
ten minutes is getting is going down or
before years exactly one smaller
proportion yep yeah and so that
disinflationary monetary supply schedule
is different than what you're talking
about which is the you're addressing the
total supply which is that 21 million
now I think a lot of people will say
that yes that's true that the total
supply is 21 million but it's
quote-unquote deflationary because every
time someone loses one it gets destroyed
etc it's essentially being taken out of
the supply your point I think is yes it
may you get to even the circulating
supply but that doesn't change the total
supply said well I would say I would say
actually even further in that while
coins are being lost all the time you
know the highest amount of losses are in
the very earliest days of Bitcoin 20
years from now
amount of bitcoins lost per day is going
to be much much lower we're gonna have
incredible custodial solutions we're
gonna have complex multi-sig we're gonna
have multiple script spending scripts so
that even if you know worst case
scenario you can still redeem it in a
couple years and you can bring those
coins back online well we'll just be
much more professional and so there
might be less coins hitting the market
and less mined per block but at the same
time we're losing less and so that
actually kind of reaches this sort of
equilibrium and I think by the time we
roll around the 21:40 the concept of
losing hundreds or thousands of coins
which might actually still happen today
much much more in common yep and
eventually you know maybe it's not 21
million is the final cap we reach but
let's say it's like you know however
many are lost let's say it's around 18
million or or 17 million it's like our
final you know amount that hasn't been
lost then the point is that it does
reach a constant it reaches an
equilibrium and that can be you know
sort of this base measurement system for
our prices and that having a nice stable
constant for our prices is very
important in the same way that you know
a meter is important or all these other
measurement systems that money is just
the measurement system for prices yep I
think that's fair what are the other
misconceptions that you think people
kind of have consensus thought about but
may not be accurate I think that another
thing that really comes up a lot is this
idea of intrinsic value and this one is
actually pretty prominent in you know
both the gold community its prominent in
popular understandings of why money is
useful and it's also popular and other
sorts of you know well you know eath is
going to be more valuable than Bitcoin
because it's gonna have all these use
cases and we need these use cases for
the Internet of Things and for supply
chain but you know when it comes down to
it a money has monetary properties that
make it valuable its scarce durable
verifiable transferable and those
monetary properties are very important
its intrinsic value its other use cases
are sort of the trade-off for that and
so when you talk about you know what
gold can be used in all these other
industrial use cases that's actually a
net negative
okay lot of money explain why because it
goes back to the idea if we want our
money monetary base to be relatively
pure right we want it to be a nice solid
constant measuring stick for signaling
to market participants about prices and
if we have this other industrial use
case that's taking gold for other sorts
of uses right and putting it in
aerospace or all of these other jewelry
dental equipment you know whatever it
might be then you're using it for a
non-monetary purpose and that can
actually create distortions and so when
we have for the first time in human
history a pure monetary object then we
can sort of get these distortions out of
our pricing mechanisms and use it simply
as this is a way of communicating prices
honestly and I think that what we're
seeing you know right now we're in San
Francisco housing here is a absolute
nightmare and that's because people
don't have you know sort of a great
store value thing and so we use other
objects for their monetary purposes and
we create other distortions in the
economy because now housing is
skyrocketing because we need other
monetary objects we need to kind of take
their monetary properties and use them
as piggy banks instead of his homes and
so you see other distortions for
monetary like things and then that just
wreaks havoc on local economies because
we don't have the sort of pure money
that is separate from all other use
cases yeah and I think this is part of
like Murad's argument right which is
that we're asking individual market
participants to have a job that drives
income so whether you're a teacher a
firefighter an investment professional
whoever there's a very small subset of
those people who also are financial
professionals so everyone else who's not
a financial professional ends up going
to work you know I'm a teacher I go to
work every day I teach these kids I get
paid my income and now because of the
structure of the financial system you're
asking me also to be an investor and
understand how to manage my capital
because if I leave it in cash it will
actually devalue over time so I need to
be able to invest it somewhere do I do
that into real estate into stocks bonds
and I don't know I have to either hand
my money over to somebody else to do it
for me or
I have to understand that and one that's
a pretty big ask if I won we shouldn't
yeah barely impossible but also the
second thing is imagine if the unit of
account was something where you could
just simply leave your wealth into that
asset and it wouldn't be devalued away
and so therefore the quote-unquote
savings mentality would work because you
can simply continue to stack right that
that amount of money that you have and
it kind of save over time right totally
totally all right what other
misconceptions do you think are out
there I think another big one is simply
the I don't even know if this is a
misconception but it's something that
frustrates me a lot and it's it's simply
the idea that people have the sort of
natural immune response to hearing ideas
that seem too good to be true and I
think this is what causes a lot of
apathy for Bitcoin because I've talked a
lot of people about Bitcoin and in some
ways I've almost stopped trying to you
know talk to you know my my friends or
my relatives about it because people
have this sort of ingrained immune
response like if you're listening to the
radio and you hear about this amazing
real estate deal that just sounds too
good to be true you're not gonna look
into it of course not because you know
we all know these things are scams right
and so Bitcoin when you're talking to
someone actually can sound so good
because it is such a revolutionary
breakthrough that it causes people to
naturally turn off because you know it's
kind of like a scaling solution to being
subjected to so many advertisements a
and day out the internet causes people
to sort of like not subjected to
rigorous logic because if you did that
for everything if I went and heard the
radio ad for the amazing real estate
opportunity and I tried to like
logically parse through why it's a
terrible idea
I would be spending every day to say
well and I think also it's such a big
idea that it's also scary all right it's
the idea of like hey we could replace
money with something that's better yeah
that's like so a sanaya many people
isn't mind that they're like nah I think
I like the current environment like it's
safer it's there's less chaos there's
less uncertainty I to go buy some food
and like I don't care what you guys are
talking about this money thing and so
it's the combination
of a big scary idea with the it almost
sounds too good to be true and when you
put those two things together the human
nature we've been conditioned over times
what you're talking about
right to reject those or kind of turn
away from them and kind of stay with the
comfortable certain you know kind of
path forward totally totally I think
that's and it is frustrating but that's
you know the way of the world early
adopters is a real thing ya know for
sure for sure alright so you've got a
bunch of ideas around Bitcoin and
politics yes the the thing to me that I
want to kind of cabbie a caveat this
part of the conversation with this there
are people who absolutely hate Bitcoin
think it's the worst thing in the world
they want to ban it etc both of the US
government and other governments and
then there's a lot of people who are
supporters right so it's oh it's not so
much but the government you know in kind
of air quotes is over generalized as
being negative towards this there are a
lot of people who actually supportive
and proponents and want to see adoption
etc why do you think that the
presidential candidates whether it's
Trump or others should like Bitcoin and
actually should be attracted to it
rather than trying to fight it I mean I
honestly think bitcoin is just such a
win-win-win for all politicians because
you can you know you can look at Bitcoin
through each of these lenses and you
know separate from which side of the
aisle you agree with no matter which
side you're on Bitcoin is a massive
boost to you know your message so like
let's say your Trump you have a very
strong sense of nationalism of an
America first mentality and you know
being an early adopter of Bitcoin is
just such a massive boon for you if you
want to be one of these early adopters
you know like we said if you're this
this first mover if you know imagine if
the United States builds up you know
substantial position in Bitcoin you know
maybe a hundred thousand coins a couple
hundred thousand I mean let's all say a
big position yep and then suddenly
announces all right we've built up a
massive position of Bitcoin we think
it's the future yep that announcement
alone causes like a 10x return yep I
mean I mean it would just be so
overwhelmingly massive yeah in the
response that you could see this like if
America does take this leadership
approach
just from a pure like profit margins
principle like you are making a massive
return like instant return on your
investment well in part of this I keep
saying it if somebody out there is
listening wants to build this please DM
me on Twitter or something but I think
it would be powerful and funny at the
same time for somebody to build a
scoreboard and literally put like the US
and China on a webpage and keep track of
how many Bitcoin each country has it's
right over at other countries in and and
you can kind of back into it probably by
how much they seized right cuz that's
pretty much how they're all getting it
today but over time right you you kind
of keep track of look there's 21 million
of these things what country is kind of
has the biggest position or is most
bullish but you use the proxy of how
many bitcoins do they actually hold on
their balance sheets in order to to
measure that again you can see them
doing this quietly and not announcing it
and then there's some announcement yeah
that's the US or some other country yeah
or you can see like what we're seeing in
China today where they just come out say
look we think blockchains - to pick one
blonde chain is the future we're going
all-in on it and that kind of like gave
the green light for everyone okay like
now let's go right let's start
announcing what we're doing etc exactly
and I think that's where the competitive
advantage comes in you know if the
United States says well actually you
know you might want to be using
blockchain for surveillance and you know
restricting your citizens personal
liberties we're gonna use it to make
ourselves great to make ourselves rich I
think that would be an incredibly
compelling narrative it even lines up
with you know the founding fathers ideas
of letting people interact how they want
and and being free from you know
centralized control and I think that you
could spin this in a very Pro America
America first move and you know Trump
really really cares about jobs about the
economy and you know that the truth is a
lot of the manufacturing jobs they're
not gonna come back right we there's
other places that do it better but
mining is something that no one really
does incredibly well yet I mean we're
still super super early and what if we
you know did a big Bitcoin mining
initiatives a push towards you know
reinvigorating the Midwest with with
mining opportunities and you know we we
love our oil and natural
industry and we know the massive
benefits the Bitcoin can bring to making
previously unprofitable and
unsustainable or non environmental
energy and natural gas industries and
bringing those online because now you
can use Bitcoin to you know capture that
and profit off that that extra energy so
it is a win-win-win for the american
workers more jobs more profitable
sectors of economy and overall it might
even get America out of this you know
sort of debt crisis that we have you
have looming because now we have the
sort of very very you know digital gold
of the digital frontier skirt school
want to know who has the best URL crypto
comm that's right
crypto comm their crypto platform with
one goal mother mass adoption that's why
we're all here we're trying to get
crypto in every wallet crypto comm is
helping people do that through buying
earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mine
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com tell them pump
Sencha and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent APY which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually
take your Bitcoin you can deposit it
with block Phi and get paid an interest
rate of 6% in return go check out block
5 comm / pump again block 5 calm / pump
to sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today and so that you really
hit on the kind of the nationalistic or
you know America first type approaches
to what bitcoin what about the other
side of the aisle which is more like
kind of the Bernie the elizabeth
warren's joe biden's etc you may be the
andrew Yang's of the world like how do
you see Bitcoin fitting into those
narratives ya know uh Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren should 100% love
Bitcoin because you know Bernie and
Elizabeth Warren are really cut from
this Occupy Wall Street idea that you
know we have these kuduk rats that are
controlling our political process
they're just you know privatizing the
gains publicizing the losses and so you
know if you start talking them well what
do you think allows them to do that
perhaps it is the can Tilian effect
perhaps it is printing money that is
financing the finance Sears right so I
mean who should be against printing
money more I mean Bernie is like first
in line because the people that are
profiting off this and who are reaping
these massive gains are like we said the
financial elite that have this not only
are they touching the money first but
they have much more deep financial
knowledge and I think that you can look
at wealth and equality and a lot of
metrics of inequality started to
increase as soon as we left the gold
standard in the early 1970s so I think
returning to a sound money a sound place
where workers can store their
hard-earned time and energy and it can't
be diluted it's going to be it seems
like such a natural idea that comes from
the sort of Occupy Wall Street mentality
of not trusting the people that are in
money instead I mean it fits this
criteria of this is the people's money
you know this is built from the ground
up a bunch of people just working hard
open-source developers just contributing
freely a lot of those ideals or what's
in the the Bernie Sanders
and you know when you look at the
federal reserve board it's a bunch of
white men they're sitting around III
think that it seems very natural they
would want to criticize this as being
you know a racist or gender institution
of the Federal Reserve Board which props
up you know the the military warfare
state that they criticize a lot it seems
to have a lot of the sticking points
that they would want and they could
point to a lot of problems in the in the
money printing business that align with
their narratives yeah for sure
it's me it also feels like if you're a
politician there's what I'll called the
the policy angle right which is kind of
the the hey this can actually help
people who need help right where I'm
gonna I'm gonna make some sort of
decision here where the policies are
employed then you have what I'll call
more the the narrative benefit right
which is this is the Andrew yang
automation is coming right you know
bitcoiners are cool
this is Trump America first right and
what you're doing is you're benefiting
from the the highly engaged community
that's already built there right so just
kind of a popularity contest tagging but
then the third thing is there is a
technology angle here right and when I
go to the technology angle I think you
know look the people who are 100 percent
exposed to the legacy financial system
and zero percent exposed to the new
financial system right or this
alternative financial system they're
making a binary bet and if they're wrong
they end up blowing themselves up right
but if you or less of a binary person
and you could say hey you know what as
president I'm going to put you know
ninety five percent of our resources in
the legacy system but there's this new
thing and we want to have a hedge you
know that basically here and if this
becomes thing we want to be the leader
we want to be out front we want to
really dictate make sure that the
American ethos are you know incorporated
into this democracy boom or whatever but
we're not gonna go a hundred percent you
know into the the new system right so
it's kind of this balance and and really
trying to almost have a confidence level
on each system but making sure that
you're gonna be a leader in either
system regards of which one wins no I
think that is some 100 roots of the case
and this kind of goes to like the third
approach you know you have your
your left and your right your strong
political candidates but you also have
the establishment you know you have your
Brad Sherman's of the world who are you
know they're not trying to beat around
the bush they know that they care about
one thing which is maintaining the u.s.
supremacy in a you know flexing our
might around the world and that's fine
and you know there's a debate to be had
there but even if you're Brad Sherman
even if you think that bitcoin could eat
your lunch it could expose your country
to weaknesses abroad and it could start
to erode your power do you really want
to take a zero bet against do you really
want to have nothing allocated to it
it's sort of this if it is so scary then
of course you should build a position of
course you should protect yourself
against it because worst-case scenario
you spend so much time railing against
it and defending the status quo that
you're not playing the long game yeah
and you let trying to build up a
position when you didn't and and that
puts you in an even scarier position so
you kind of have to address the
realities as it is and you can't just
daydream about the you know the yester
years where you had the complete
monopoly over what people use for their
everyday transactions so speaking of
politics bitcoins one component of it
right but when you look back at whether
it's defy whether you look at smart
contracts it's just kind of all the
other aspects of the ecosystem or
industry how do you see that playing
into the political narrative and
especially as a presidential election
comes up you know like is it just that
hey focus on Bitcoin if you're a
candidate or do you think that the rest
of this is just as important and are
things that they should be addressing as
they kind of you know propose their
plans for the country uh I mean honestly
that that's a it's a tough question and
I think that campaigns are trying to
adjust their strategy towards the sort
of new weird viral environment that we
see and I think that honestly that's
what led to a lot of Trump success is a
brilliant campaign of viral you know
things that he knew would go viral and
would resonate with certain people
through memes I think me more fair is
the new sort of you know it's not going
to be establishment media anymore
right before this interview we're
looking at sort of the project Veritas
stuff the Jeffrey I've seen stuff and
that's a really powerful new force that
I don't really think anyone knows so
explain a little bit about what's going
on there so project Veritas is this sort
of it's it's a campaign or it's a it's a
organization a group that's trying to
expose biases and traditional media
outlets and just this morning they
released a video of I think it's one of
the hosts of an ABC talk-show who is you
know on a hot mic and there she was
talking to producers about how she if
she had all this information about
Epstein that people weren't letting it
come out and they were sort of trying to
suppress the stuff that she had been
doing for years and that she thought it
was interesting all this was coming to
light and people start to care but she
had been you know kind of pushed to the
background for a long time and said no
one cares about this even though they
had extremely damning evidence and you
know this is sort of this really strange
outcome that I don't think that anyone
can can do anything about where you have
you know as the Internet becomes more
and more powerful suddenly you can't
stop people from saying things in the
way that you could previously and so you
have all new source of information and
disinformation warfare that I don't
really know how we handle going forward
but it'll be really interesting it's
this idea that like viral content is
just propaganda for the masses yeah yeah
I think it is and and that's not
surprising and in a way we had it's not
that there's more or less truth but
there's just more sources of it now that
we're sort of entering this information
age and I think it's overwhelming right
now and and hopefully it'll sort of get
better but I don't know I think a lot of
the things that we're seeing in Hong
Kong and simultaneously in other parts
around the world and in Argentina and
Lebanon and Catalonia and all of these
sort of populist movements that are now
virally connected and can see their
successes and failures in other parts of
the world is another part of this and
it's sort of a broader shift that
Bitcoin is a part of which is a shift
from you know the sort of cathedral
environment of very close systems
and you know I was just rereading
cathedral and the bazaar just a couple
days ago and it was really striking how
true not only it is from the open-source
software perspective but just for so
many legacy institutions whether it be
education or or healthcare or a lot of
these sorts of things that it's it's
becoming more and more obvious that the
the less Cathedral approach we take to
things the more we open things up and
say all right you can just learn
whatever you want now I mean we
basically made liberal are like like
like Liberal Studies degrees your social
sciences degrees those are basically
useless now yep when you can learn a lot
I mean in college I study philosophy I
learned probably like five times as much
just from reading online yep about
philosophy than anything you learn in
class how much of the college experience
though in those liberal arts do you
think are driven less about the
knowledge that you can obtain because
you can go read that online in books etc
and it's more about the the kind of
interactions with other people who are
thinking about the same things it's the
it's the debates it's the disagreements
it's like kind of the conversation
around the information which I would
consider is the more subjective
component of what you're able to get
online I think that there's a lot of
glamorization romanticism around this
sort of thing but the reality is a lot
of kids don't go to class now many
people won't really care a lot of people
just kind of show up for the credits a
lot of people are just you know oh I'm
taking this required music class yeah
because I have to get my music
requirement I have physical education no
no one cares but when you look at things
like Twitter like there's a lot of
really really interesting just sort of
like radical philosophy that happens on
Twitter and these like crazy threads and
and so Twitter I see is like or you know
it's similar platforms to it I think
Twitter is a good example of you can
have the sort of open source education
open source to debate and discussion if
you really like these sorts of
commingling of ideas I mean that's
exactly what Twitter is each tweet is
about the size of something you would
you would say in a conversation because
a conversation it has natural
and forth you know and so tweets can
kind of go back and forth but not only
that you can have functionality that you
can't have in a classroom because a
classroom conversation is necessarily
linear but in a tweet you can say
something and then you can take all
three responses to it and each of those
can branch out and create their own
debates and so when you take it online
you can actually have much much more
stimulating valuable and free and
interesting because the people aren't
forced to be there you don't have a
forced participating on Twitter the
people that talk on Twitter other people
have care and and I think Bitcoin has
shown just how powerful this can be yeah
that when you have an open source
pursuit of truth that you can resist
corporate attacks you can resist all
these sorts of corruptions that that
sort of eat their way in
I think the UA SF and the resistance of
segue to X is a amazing example of how
powerful yeah these new the you know the
academic institutions are I would
consider Bitcoin Twitter an academic
institution and you're not there because
of your tenure position yeah you're
there because you make a damn good
argument people agree with you and you
you sort of build up that following
through you know just making strong
logical points yeah I think a lot about
Twitter is a war of ideas right and like
people that don't understand the nuances
of Twitter think that it is conversation
but what I've come to find out is it
really is a war of ideas and I use the
wor the words war of ideas specifically
because what ends up happening is you
get people who come with their own
perspective on the world and the the
nature of Twitter's you have to post
that publicly right so you have to to
post this to the masses and then you
have to sit and defend right so you go
from an offensive position where hey
this is an idea and then it's just an
attack and especially around Bitcoin
where people are definitely there's a
come on come robbery right around like
hey we all are going after the same
thing but bitcoiners are very very quick
whether I like you or not if you say
something I disagree with like we are
here to have that that kind of attrition
right yeah it's like what are the best
ideas what can survive the attacks and
so it's the one place in the world where
I feel like you can put ideas out to a
large mass of people you can then
immediately like become defensive as
they attack it gets a defendant right
all this stuff but at the end of it all
we all are there for the same reason
right oh so it's like it's like this
very interesting kind of like the salons
of you know many decades ago but do you
think that the way we are communicating
today is changing the way that people
actually think what I mean by this is so
think of Twitter right very short form
kind of micro blogging I think of memes
right and kind of the way that we are
able to mean things whether it's through
text or visual or video etc like does
the the communication delivery right or
are they almost the the media format
change the arguments does it change the
way that we think does it make us almost
dumber or do you think that this is just
us adapting to technology and if we
still have the same level of
intellectual curiosity in depth it's
just now we're just kind of fermenting
that in a different form factor I think
I think it's a it's tempting to say
we're getting dumbed down and I think
it's given you choices you know maybe
things were were more rigorous or higher
quality or like the average level of
content or something previously and you
only had sort of like all right you have
three TV channels and you can only
listen to what's on there and you sort
of get the the standard narrative yep I
think this Internet has certainly given
you the freedom to just purely just
download garbage to your brain but on
the other hand it is incredibly
liberating and I think can promote
people who are you know your your
modern-day da vinci's you know people
who are the polymath the Satoshi's of
the world they now have the Liberty to
explore whatever they want to engage in
incredibly rigorous discussion and
debates and thinking through very very
high-level topics on 20 different issues
20 different fields and it could be
someone who just has an internet
connection anywhere in the world and
that I think we're gonna see I mean it's
it's crazy to imagine how powerful that
is yeah you know if in the past 500
years there have been thousands of
potential da vinci's but only a few of
them had access to the resources in the
libraries that made their ideas come to
life and make these mass improvements
well if we're democratizing that if
we're opening up these conversations so
you can join these salons wherever you
want you can read these you know very
important texts whenever you want maybe
some people are gonna download garbage
but those people probably would have
done something relatively useless it was
the same thing like you could read The
Washington Post or you could read the
National Enquirer right and you could
have done that three decades ago right
and so it was your your choice of
information you actually have more
choice now and not only have more choice
but the thing I love is the the power
shift from the institutions to the
individuals right on Twitter there is no
difference between an individual in the
Washington Post because at the end of
the day you may actually trust that
individual more than the Washington Post
right and that's not a knock against the
Washington Post it's just that the that
the internet specifically creates the
opportunity for authenticity and when
you have authenticity that's where Trust
is going right and totally I think
that's very hard for an institution to
have authenticity because it's not a
human right and it's a collection of
humans and so which human represents the
authenticity well you really don't have
an answer to that right and so at that
level when you are you know going back
to the idea of pseudonyms when you're on
a pseudonymous level the only way I can
tell if they're authentic enough is if
you have a good logical argument behind
you
yeah the credibility that many of these
very powerful institutions have you know
sort of rested on for so long as being
called in question because here are
people making very strong credible
arguments and if that is a strong
argument then it gets retweeted and it
goes viral and you know you sort of see
this power dynamic come into play where
you can't simply just be a traditionally
credible thing you have to back up what
you're saying with strong arguments yep
it's so when you think about kind of the
we'll call it the verification right
there's a lot of similarities between
the verification of ideas and and cons
on twitter as there is with Bitcoin as
money right this whole idea of like
fully transparent system that I can
verify every transaction etc do you
think that that is that mechanism or
model will permeate itself into all
aspects of our lives where people will
just demand the ability to verify or do
you think that it will still be certain
aspects of society where I just trust
this institution or this individual and
I don't need that ability to verify like
does the Internet break the model and
require verification yeah or is that
just on the extremes of maybe
information money may be one or two
other areas I see this is sort of like a
much longer shift I think that you know
in the 40s or 50s maybe we had strong
trust but as we've gotten better at
peeling the layers back and seeing
what's actually happening in other parts
of the world
I think Vietnam War was like the Vietnam
War is a very big turning point for
American identity because we started to
see the official narratives hard to be
questioned by okay here's real
journalists on the ground here's what
they're saying about kill counts here's
what they're seeing about soldiers
fragging their own officers here's what
they're seeing about who is actually
being killed all these were just like
symbolic shocks to official narratives
yep and I don't see I just see this as
being a progressive thing I think as
time progresses we're going to see more
and more questioning of official
narratives yeah and instead we're gonna
see more sort of populist I don't know
if populist is the right word viral
movements I think is through is the
right one and I don't even know if it's
necessarily democratic because I think
there's also some question about
democracy as well going into the 21st
century in the narrative this well right
right I think like one of the things
I've become really interested in is
these ideas that hey there's this cause
right so let's take two examples one
would be protocol Russia meddled in the
election and they caused dissent between
American citizens and they create chaos
and controversy and that patent impact
the other would be that you're a
political candidate I'm a political
candidate you are gonna have a rally so
I threw my campaign fund counter
protesters to show up right and I'm
really paying them to be there those two
things seem pretty similar to me right
and so it depends on it where's the line
right so is it just another country or
government we don't want them to do that
but you and I meddling and with each
other it is okay because we call that
democracy yeah but where this all kind
of materializes is like do you think
that they eat those of Bitcoin and
Bitcoin errs is going to drive change in
the world or do you think that's simply
the popularity of those ethos is the
product of a change that's happening in
the world right so what they see is I
think the second one is right I think
that more I think this is definitely a
shift towards distrust of any sort of
larger institution money being one of
them education being another media being
a third and I don't think I think
honestly it's it's hard because I think
that personally bitcoin has changed my
perspective and so I can see them
feeding on each other
I think the reason people are drawn to
Bitcoin is this idea of you know it
makes sense to have an algorithm instead
of a person that I'm trusting and to
sort of minimize trust and I think that
that's largely something that has come
about more with this sort of
peer-to-peer internet culture as people
are becoming more cynical about the
world but I also think that Bitcoin
realigns our values it's definitely
realigned mine where I found myself much
much more skeptical of any sort of
interference and any sort of tinkering
or optimization instead Bitcoin
represents sort of this pure base where
it doesn't matter necessarily what the
numbers are it doesn't matter you know
what the block size is there's there
some like wiggle room there it doesn't
matter exactly how many coins are but
the fact that it is a unflinching just
constant in my life and in in knowing
what it guarantees me is something that
is incredibly powerful and I see that as
as being something that money is
uniquely based on trust right now and I
think we could move away from that other
things it's hard
it's it's nice to take trust out of
money but you can't do the same thing
with with a lot of these other
institutions that are going to be facing
a reckoning because you know how do you
remove trust from academic arguments you
know you still need to parse out logic
you still need to go through these other
how do you remove trust from you know
media or something like that eventually
someone has to be selecting which
arguments are good or bad and you have
to to understand where the logic is
coming from but I don't know it's very
deeply complex and so it's definite
complex yes sure yeah and there's no
black and white answer I guess really
what ends up the way that I think about
this is if you continue to use
technology to break apart the
corporations and kind of the trusted
narratives and kind of all of this stuff
and you end up hitting at like what do
we what can we verify and if we can
verify can we trust it how that
permeates because if you look at the
major cortical institutions of our
society these are all things that
actually require the default trust so
governments money right you know media
etc and if you start to break those down
into I need to be able to verify what
you get is a world that looks very very
different and my greatest fear is that
there's a lot of pain between where we
are and where we're going and it's how
do you navigate that pain yeah I mean
the I think a lot of people I think
everyone knows something is wrong and
it's it's not just a fear it's reality
you know pensions don't have the money
our government's insolvent the eurozone
is insolvent the China is just you know
propping yourself up on debt on top of
debt on top of debt you know all of
these massive legacy financial
institutions do not have a much of
runway left you know maybe it's ten
years maybe it's 20 years maybe it's two
years I don't know who knows no one
knows what this straw is gonna break the
camel's back but we know that something
is going to have to give in these
traditional systems and you know the
sovereign individual is a fantastic book
that talks about the sort of shift and
how it's it's going to happen it has to
happen because these things aren't
sustainable much like the shift from you
know
the the power of the church and how it
eventually became the sort of parasitic
institution that eventually had to be
cleansed yep but that wasn't a fun time
yep
that was a hard time a very hard time
and I brought a lot of pain and I think
there's no clean way to get from where
we are now to this sort of new open more
bottom-up system without pain along the
way because so many people are still
relying on narratives that you and I
both know are just bunk at the end of
the day and you know when when it comes
down to people's I mean this is this is
serious this is people's life savings
this is people's pensions that they've
been working for for years as a teacher
because they know they're going to get
that nice pension at the end of it
that's why they've been making these
sacrifices and on the other end and
they're either not going to get their
money or the only way they can get their
money is through massive tax increases
yep on the other local citizens yep who
have been planning not to have those tax
increases and have been you know you
know scrupulously saving and trying to
make ends meet just to make sure they
can't have the retirement and suddenly
are you gonna raise taxes on those
people to pay the pensions that need to
be bailed out for sure are you just
gonna print money and inflate away what
do you think people savings I mean
that's obviously the the plan is a sexy
political move but that's also and this
goes back to what we're talking about
earlier inflation is a one of the worst
ways to handle problems in your society
because it's so regressive yeah
inflation hurts the worst off because
the the people in in higher level
incomes they can you know shield their
money and these sorts of different
financial assets yeah but the you know
the lower bracket of the underside of
Americans can't afford $400 emergency
payment exactly right exactly and they
keep their savings their bank accounts
and keep their savings and they don't
have no stocks yep no of course not of
course not yep and we shouldn't expect
them to we shouldn't expect them to but
inflation then becomes this silent
regressive tax that you can sort of you
know scapegoat around and say oh it's
you know all these different things
except
for what's actually happening I don't
know how any of these play out and I
think anyone who says they know how it's
gonna play out you should run the other
direction because we're dealing with
monumental complexity but I think what
we do know is there is going to be pain
unfortunately yeah and because you know
we've been sold a system that's just
broken yep and it's been running on
fumes for a while and maybe I'll
continue yeah um but I see Bitcoin as a
safe haven for that because I know no
matter where I'm at in the world no
matter who is in charge 21 million yeah
is going to stay yep and that is
something that is just unbelievably
powerful looking at these long-term
consequences five 10 20 years down the
road
yeah for sure what uh as we've got to
wrap up what are you most excited about
kind of over the next 12 months so what
do you pay attention to what do you
think is is really exciting oh gosh I
think there's so many things are really
exciting I honestly in terms of Bitcoin
development itself I'm just really
excited for how the lighting networks
being built out I was just in Berlin for
the Lightning conference awesome how's
that oh it was fantastic
everyone there was really really
interested in building and not you know
I also went to the block sack conference
and it was a completely different
mentality at the two different
conferences one was very interested in
ideas and theories and you know what
what can we do beyond Facebook where as
lightning conference was here for we're
building here's how it works
here's how we expect this to work six
months from now here's how this is going
to be an integral part of a brand new
financial infrastructure and this is
only going to get exponentially better
and here's the new layers on top of this
and here's the research we're doing and
you know they're they're not pulling
punches they're not trying to dumb
anything down and the people there are
ridiculously motivated at making things
not making money and that's a very very
different approach and it's the open
source ethos of the best things are
gonna be built when people who care
about them are building them yeah and
not people who you know have seven
million dollars and they're trying to
think about what's the best way to
allocate this because people they just
want to build stuff and so you know what
what's happening at light
specifically with different ways of
routing so atomic multipath payments so
you can break up different routes so if
I want to send you $10 I can send it
five dollars through two different
channels instead of get one $10 channel
you have massive improvement in
enlightening UX and I think at this
point we're beyond proof of concept like
we're really building this stuff out and
we're not just through crafting we've
done it we've basically finished
replacing the Federal Reserve it's just
a question of time we're just waiting
for these things to come to fruition
but all the difficult questions the
innovations are there it's just a
question of you know iterating iterating
iterating and and and and making this
all happen and in the context of the
macro backdrop that is sort of the one
thing that that helps me feel confident
about the future if we didn't have
Bitcoin it would be much much darker
yeah and yeah I don't even like to think
about what's the Oh what's the most
important book you've read I have most
important book I've read ever honestly
the first thing that comes to mind is a
it's a Nietzsche reader by RJ Hallandale
who put it together and it's basically a
collection of Nietzsche's philosophical
writings interesting it was really
really important for me going into
college because you know Nietzsche was
kind of this philosophical person who
just blew open traditional
understandings of philosophy and said
you know all these guys that are putting
these brilliant philosophy chairs and
all these high institutions they're
wrong yep they're just preaching about
stuff that you know isn't should be
accepted as truth you know and the truth
is much much stickier than a black and
white good and bad but that all these
things are much more great and I think
that that mentality of questioning
whoever the truth that whoever claims to
have an understanding of truth
questioning that has been really
important for orienting my politics and
view of the world and turning it more
towards what what what really Bitcoin
represents also which is we should just
let people do what they want we should
trust in people's opinions to you know
whatever they voluntarily choose to do
and I think it also helped me sort of
parse through mainstream and economic
understandings of Bitcoin versus where
does the logical arguments stack up and
if you can make a good argument
it doesn't matter of what titles you
have what credentials you have but the
the where you should go is is where the
the logic structures are yeah for sure
before I end I always like you ask me
one question but we talked about aliens
believer non-believer honest aliens I am
very disappointed in basically all
modern representations of aliens okay
because you know if you look at Star
Wars or you look at these you know
popular understanding or even even what
people claim was here at the Roswell
stuff yep
the aliens are always very very humanoid
you know their arms they have legs they
even have eyeballs the idea that aliens
will even have the same sensory organs
as humans you know we come from a nice
clean little genetic line going back all
these millions of years to our ancestors
but over the years we've kind of
developed certain sense organs eyes ears
you know whatever it might be and most
animals on earth have that but there's
no reason to think that other alien
species will have the same way of even
interacting with the physical forces of
the universe so I think we could get a
lot more creative with our aliens but I
definitely think they exist just
statistically they have to exist yeah I
mean let's just be real I just want to
see some more creative thought in aliens
that's fair what one question yet for me
to finish up one question I have for you
it's really hard pump no question is
perfectly fun makes my job easy I would
say what is your I'm curious um what is
your favorite podcast in crypto right
now aside from your might my favorite
podcasting crypto um man that's really
good so I can't pick one I'm gonna pick
two and it's because they they come at
it from very different perspectives so I
would go with telling the Crypt Marty
bent Matt O'Dell
and then Peter mcCormick what bitcoin
did I think both of them one is much
more individual focused right so like
when Peters interviewing people etc he
just did one with Nick Szabo that I
thought was fantastic
um yeah he's got a number of other ones
that uh that I would highly recommend it
so it's it's to me I got to learn a lot
from somebody that Peter got some
questions to and kind of talking about
when it comes to Marty and Matt their
their little rabbit hole recap I think
that's what is to me the part that I
like about that is you get to follow
their thought process right and so it's
like you're hearing them constantly
sharing like their perspective on the
news and I think that what I find
valuable to them specifically is they
come from a much more kind of Bitcoin
centric earlier time period right where
they've just been around for much longer
than a lot of people and so they have
kind of historical context of Bitcoin
specifically and then they have a very
specific perspective on the world right
and that perspective it's not very
widely shared by a lot of people then
they're just entertaining right okay so
now there's so if you kind of like wrap
all that together for me it's like it's
enjoyable but it's also educational I
don't know what from it and so I
actually think that's one of the biggest
problems with podcast today is a lot of
people are very focused on making them
educational but not entertaining and I
that's always my advice to people it's
like hey if you're gonna do some sort of
content like make it enjoyable and
entertaining and then make it substitute
behind it but I think that first part
gets left out which they've they've
obviously done a great job with
it's there's the chip I would recommend
it's awesome yeah all right man listen
thanks so much for taking the time to do
this I think people will enjoy it I'm
sure plenty of people will be mad at us
about talking about politics Bitcoin and
the social constructs of the world I
mean that's the we're here for right but
thank you so much for having me on pump
exactly where can people find you online
if they want to reach out the best place
was just on my Twitter its underscore
Connor Brown underscore and that's
Connor with an ER yeah somebody had
Connor Browns at Connor Brown yes go
track him down man I'm one of these
things
I appreciate it yep hey everyone pop
here if you like this episode of off the
chain and want to help us take crypto to
the top of the Apple Spotify and other
podcast charts please do us a favor and
rate review and subscribe to review
simply go to the off-the-chain homepage
scroll down until you see the five blank
stars taking 15 seconds to fill those
stars in and leave a quick review goes a
long way in helping us take the entire
crypto ecosystem to the top of the
charts I appreciate you listening and
see you next time on off the chain
you